chris hadfield now he joins us live from
Kings Cross in central London hello to
you Chris thanks for joining us here on
Sky News this afternoon sensational
photographs in the book that you are
just launching um what's it like being
in space you know that clip you just
showed Kay where something is simple and
predictable as just wringing out a cloth
that everybody knows how that's going to
be as soon as you get yourself to kind
of a brand-new environment suddenly
something completely surprising happens
and and I think 13 or 14 million people
have watched that little clip because
they were surprised when we push
ourselves right to the very limit and
living on board a spaceship
living in space off the planet is
constantly like that with the way things
behave on the inside but as is in the
book the way the world truly looks from
the outside it's it's constantly
mesmerizing you're the first Canadian to
ever walk in space how did that feel you
know we don't go outside lightly it's
not it's not like in the movies
we only go outside on a spacewalk for a
really specific purpose because it's
dangerous but when it happens it's like
every astronauts dream it is you are
alone in the universe
you're you're in between the world and
everything else and the world is is
slowly silently majestically turning
next to you and you're holding on to
everything holding on to your one link
with humanity with one hand the the
perspective on kind of where we are in
history just slaps you in the face and
seeing the whole world in sort of an
honesty of how it truly is it's it's
it's something I dreamed about since I
was a little boy but it's even better
than that when you have a chance to do
it for real you know it's certainly a
long way from that farm in Ontario isn't
it fact you were inspired I believe by
the moon landing I was inspired I was
first inspired by science fiction books
and and movies but I was even more
inspired by the first people who were
actually going to space with Yuri
Gagarin and
and Al Shepard and John Glenn but then
when the first two of us walked on the
moon when Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin
walked on the moon to me it was just
manifestation of the fact that that
impossible things can happen in my
lifetime and it really inspired me to
change who I was and to pursue those
things and amazingly enough to fly in
space three different times and
eventually command the the International
Space Station yeah exactly so what was I
how difficult how much of a challenge is
it to be part of the International Space
Station not least being commander and
being responsible for everyone else's
health and safety while you're there how
is everyday living while you're there
well the stakes are extremely high kay
if you make a mistake
everybody dies and you destroy the world
spaceship so so the stakes are extremely
high and there's no one really to help
you the six of us on board are separate
from Earth the best earth can do is sort
of give us advice so it's it's an
immense task to try and do it properly
and we we take it really seriously I
trained as an astronaut for twenty-one
years I learned to speak Russian to fly
a Russian spaceship and and built a team
with people that I thought could handle
no matter what happened and all sorts of
stuff happened but we were successful
but it's also just such a magnificent
human experience a personal experience
and that's what I did my very best to
share with everyone we're looking at you
brushing your teeth is with chatting to
you will you ever frightened you try not
to have an astronaut who's afraid it no
one wants a frightened astronaut think
that means you didn't get ready it means
it means you weren't prepared for what
was going to happen which you really
never try and get yourself into you
don't want to be relying on your
instinct to fly a spaceship so that's
why we spend so much of our lives so
many years preparing just for that so
once in a while you get a little shiver
of fear up your back when something
truly
random happens like if you see a
meteorite burn up in the atmosphere of
beneath you you know that that rock went
by your spaceship on the way to crashing
into the earth so that reminds you of
the fragility of where you are but but
that's true no matter where you live it
you don't have to be on a spaceship to
know that we're all mortal and I think
the magnificence of it the opportunity
of it and what we're learning from it
way outstrips any transient fears that
that you might have to deal with looking
at these fantastic images in your book
you are here you first started putting
these on Twitter and you were described
as perhaps the most social media savvy
astronaut ever to leave Earth where you
were where while you were in space of
your popularity you know I just took
those pictures Kay because you can't
help it the world is so generously
beautiful and it changes every time you
come around and you go around sixteen
times a day so I was taking the pictures
regardless but luckily just within the
last few years we have basic internet so
I could I could not just keep them to
myself but I could I could write
something on Twitter and hit Send and
and it was delightful to become aware of
the reaction to see the hundreds of
thousands and then millions of people
that were were along for the voyage with
me and where we're really seeing earth
through my eyes seeing earth clearly
maybe in a way they'd never seen it
before it it was both motivating but
also really heartening to be able to
share it that way the application of
technology for better self awareness and
understanding I did what it's a lovely
position to be in as an astronaut but
it's really nice to be able to share it
with so many folks now you have retired
although you did celebrate one or two
anniversaries in space I believe while
you were there looking forward how far
away do you think we are from a moon
colony I don't think we're very far from
a moon colony
we've been living on the space station
for 15 years just a couple weeks ago so
if you're 15 years or younger
you have never been alive when there
weren't human beings living off the
planet there's never been a second and
so we've colonized
the orbit of the earth and it's not that
far to the moon it's only three days
away you know it's like a long drive
across Europe so we will colonize the
moon next I'm confident it's the obvious
next destination and just as we've
slowly spread over the whole surface of
the earth and in the last hundred years
colonized down into Antarctica I think
that pattern is just using the
technology going to repeat going to the
moon and then eventually even further
but but we still have to allow ourselves
to get a lot of things wrong sort it out
not kill everybody and learn everything
that comes back from it I'm hoping to
see people permanently living on the
moon within my lifetime and if you had
any regrets would it be that you never
went to the moon
I don't live with regrets I have been so
lucky that's such a rich existence even
so far I'm I'm a very lucky man and sure
I'd love to go to the moon but regret is
a choice no I if I get a chance I'll try
and get ready and go but but I am the
first one to recognize just how
incredibly fortunate I've been to this
point to have been the person that took
all those pictures you know this this is
just a small handful of the thousands
and thousands of things that I've seen
in the world
I like pinch myself what's with what the
luck that I've had but if you're asking
I'd love to go to the moon sure yeah I'm
just looking at the book as were
chatting to you such a shame you're not
here so that you can sign it but we may
be in another lifetime it's great to
talk to you thanks very much to do for
Joni Ernst on Sky News this afternoon
and good luck with a book thank you
thank you very much I'll take all the
luck I could get thank you thank you